oui l'addiction est présente bien de
vous excuser le jour 2 se trouve sur
seize ans par lyon perd pas tant vaut
finir 1er c'est parti
first le premier état 29000 franchement
c'est jouable c'est très très jouable on
va manger on va manger on va se faire
tout seul frère ouah ouah non on
s'appelle abus voilà parce que c'était
de la bu mais nommés mais faut arrêter d
en fait il ya du ping je vous adore
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est pas les
excuses du mec nul on a des capacités
faut qu'on les exploite
allez on va aller vers le sort toujours
l'air le centre c'est là où il ya tous
les gros tous les petits sont pas cons
ils viennent vers le centre ces [ __ ]
drâa ça t'apprendra à prendre en chasse
plus gros que toi
là en plus cela vous n'avez pas mais ça
faisait 20 minutes que j'étais comme ça
en train de trahir y avait un silence
radio chez moi oh oui merci mec on a tué
le grand mail et des grenades
on est presque dans le top 10 grâce à ça
va être ta came où aucun des 9e il va
situer le gros rouge l'a regardé le
regarder
là c'est bon tu fais quoi toi mais sauf
[ __ ] c'était à moi c'était à moi et
m'ont tout volé je me suis levé ce matin
j'ai mangé un ramène pouf naruto était
devant moi ne vous en faites pas 4e je
trouve je trouve jelma mois depuis ta
chance que j'ai non je le voyais où va
la jouer ici tu me la joues fdp surtout
on a touché notre rêve du bout des
doigts comme ça et il s'est envolé au
revoir un plaisir de faire cette blague
et de mourir squeeze 10e parce qu'on va
faire ce que je dis c'est que je vais te
tuer et je vais vraiment te manger ok on
à 2900 c'est pas dégueu encore 10 fois
ça y est on est premier au début ça a
l'air simple mais pas du tout oh là là
on l'a doublée
attends pas le mec s'est donné pour tuer
ce qu'on appelle un verre d'aliments
quoi c'était pas ma que c'était celle
d'un doute
je vole de lautrec ça marchera l'on sait
jamais on lui voyez lui j'ai envie de
leur acte voilà ça c'est moi si j'avais
tenté un truc
la technique de deux chemins où le ton
tout coup et je te viole olalala de bol
c'est abusé ce que j'ai fait du coup
j'ai perdu un mari je suis terrorisée
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça reste
une mine d'or
non mais non pourquoi c'est moi qui perd
le duel pourquoi mon voyage vers les
nuages et plus grosses têtes recul et
j'en suis sûre quand j'étais petit on se
moquait de moi parce que j'avais un
grand front et frost regardes tu vas
avoir froid et put à la poche a été
pourri le mauvais temps pourri tout
était nul ayhan grande que je parle pas
de celle de mon caleçon heil a vu la
butte
bientôt ces thèmes comme le plus long et
le plus nul que des vues 1 messieurs
dames en bien faire notre entrée dans le
top 10 d'un
allez désolé désolé mon bien auplata
voulu mulema bouffe ttt dans la mer bros
t'es dans la merde allez on t'a baiser à
12 la technique c'est en fait c'est
d'encercler la monnaie comme ça personne
veuillez accéder au toit était mort
vieux
là à la bouche en [ __ ] j'ai envie de
tenter un move de tubes ferrari
telle une ferrari j'arrive je vis dans
l'est pourquoi c'est lui qui m'a eu
ok je rigole plus aux e mails non il a
fait pire que nous enfin que je pense
que pour être premier pas vers la
technique d'aidé fdp tueur est appuyé
dans l'ombre et des gueulards jours à
paris tu fonces ouais voilà voilà qu'est
ce que je veux dire
non même nom mais là on peut poser une
main courante au commissariat pour ce
qui vient de se passer ou pas là aux
essais nucci l'eau les gens c'est des
gros chiens quoi qu avec meurt tout le
monde est là elle mangeait on n'est pas
comme ça nous on attend poliment mais sa
petite serviette ici on prend ses
couverts mais son coût dans un kebab
on parle de gastronomie ok tu peux
mourir ça me soulagera merci n'est que
tu es un vrai pote
quand il est mort aux halles et
gastronomes et gastronomie on se dépêche
pas non mais c'est au lala gros pactole
pour le cas où chars pourquoi c'est
toujours moi qui prend cher bébé
pourquoi on prend mon carnet
correspondance alors c'est même pas moi
qui parle est pourquoi dans slider
coillot c'est moi qui perd en frontal je
sais plus quoi faire en plus une en
train de tomber enrhumé ça cassez-vous
la ceiba bouffe c'est moi qui ai fait le
move
[ __ ] raison tu as oui tiens je disais
pourquoi dans la fpt croire en ses rêves
il faut jamais abandonner
aujourd'hui on abandonne
désolé mec
oh la la c'est la fête là mon gars
thomas cook est une affaire où y'a
jamais perdre ses rêves de vue ça fait
déjà une heure on n'a pas pour autant
fait dès qu'on arrive aux alentours des
10 milles ça devient très dur parce que
il faut vraiment penser chaque bouffe
que tu fais c'était beaucoup
tiens ça le bâtard ça t'apprendra
c'était ma nourriture c'est moi que
facebook de j'ai dit ok omate assez à
bail
d'accord je pète la gueule oh oui oh oui
oh [ __ ] le petit bâtard de mer quoi sa
part sur une huitième place
on est concentré mais attention pas se
précipiter pas se précipiter à la
gastronomie la gastronomie dont le haut
est la faille susi des locaux 6 6 2
stark jackpot du nom on est quatrième on
touche le rêve du bout des doigts et les
larves faut surtout pas faire de la
merde pas comme lui vous voyez on n'est
pas loin de la première place
voyez toujours en grève essayez
d'atteindre vos objectifs et donner à
fond tu pas très fort pour les discours
d'allégeance regarde cette vidéo sur ce
live radio n'hésitez pas l'aimer c'est
vous a plu [ __ ] on est premier en
seulement deux vidéos est ce qu'on peut
dire que lorsqu il était là en avant des
mois ce qui va se passer à l'adresse de
prochaines vidéos portez vous bien
documents office
en
à